[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud and do not
give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] him
[Music]
good good morning
happy presidents day
as we are celebrating today
all the presidents
that are legitimate
viable
that don't have the cheeto dust stain to
them
[ __ ] that guy [ __ ] that guy [ __ ] that
guy we will not celebrate number 45
today for president's day he's not
invited to anything anyways have you
ever noticed that
like when they have the president's at
like a an event whether it be like a
funeral of of a former senator former
president or someone important important
that guy is never invited i wonder why i
wonder why he's never invited
hmm
could there be something to that i guess
there could be and apparently um he
can't figure out how to [ __ ] work a
goddamn social media app that he's
copied
the [ __ ] thing's a direct copy
how the hell doesn't this thing work
you just [ __ ] copied it and it
doesn't work true social
you can't even get on that son of a
[ __ ] apparently it's down it's down
true social down what never was up is
the problem
i don't know i i think i think maybe
this guy is trying to get to this uh
true social quicker than they
anticipated and the reason why is
because he thinks the tweets are gonna
save him from prosecution maybe or
something i don't know
and that's the thing is do you truth on
the truth social d truce
do you trust do you put truth
and i don't get it like it's gonna be
called a tweet
like that's what it's gonna be called
you dumb [ __ ] it's gonna be
called a tweet you're gonna tweet on
true social so they already [ __ ]
their branding's [ __ ] it's completely
[ __ ]
completely [ __ ] you don't buy facial
tissues you buy kleenex
right
i mean yeah you buy the off-brand every
once in a while but it's [ __ ] a
kleenex right
i'm just saying
it's
true you're gonna tweet on truth and
that's gonna [ __ ] them up uh everyone's
saying hi hi patty
good morning eugene good morning
mj welcome as always
the [ __ ] fam
uh david says hi
so yeah i mean you know
it's it's a situation where
the branding is off and you think this
guy's supposed to oh he's the major
brander that's he's so great at it he's
such a great brander
what not in this instance
not in this instance which
leads you to believe that he's not a
good brander at all anyways
i mean he's kind of destroyed his
[ __ ] he's kind of destroyed his
[ __ ] brand now
just completely [ __ ] trashed it
absolutely [ __ ] trashed it uh suzy
says hi great show as always
uh carter says morning good morning
carter welcome to everyone to the show
it's gonna be a great week here
since we're starting off with a federal
holiday of president's day
and i'm sure we're going to have a lot
of news this week that is going to drop
but we actually
on the show we have already several
interviews in the can already that we're
going to be bringing to you this week so
i want to i want to announce this at the
top here
that we're going to have several
interviews they're fantastic interviews
one i don't want to give too much away
um gabe will kill me if i give too much
away
but it has to do with the trucker convoy
and possibly go give send go
and some news on that so
that's a great interview we're hoping we
will have that out tomorrow or wednesday
we will probably know more this
afternoon we'll tweet out maybe
when that interview will drop
it's kind of a longer interview so it'll
probably take up because of all the
information in it
it might take up
an entirety of an episode almost just
because there's so much info
that we got out of this interview um
when when looking
at uh some of the gives and go
information as you guys know you've
probably seen in the news they've got a
lot of big donors that they kind of
tracked down
um with this gives and go um data dump
or data leak but there's a lot more to
it
and this interview we we break all that
down so there's there's some news that
possibly we will break there
uh we also have a candidate this week
um that i i found on social media that i
think is doing a wonderful job
and um i wanted to highlight his
candidacy
and so it's a quick learner interview
but it's a really good it's a really
good interview to show you the the the
energy behind pro-democracy
and that's super important that's super
super super important is that energy
behind pro-democracy because we have
cpac coming up
so they're already probably building the
the nazi stage
uh as we speak i tweeted this morning i
wonder let's see let's go to that let's
go let's go to the uh to the to the nazi
stage tweet i don't want to i don't want
to deprive you that's about the only
thing i tweeted this morning it says
how's the not how's the stage coming for
cpac
wonderbar i'm sure
you know it's the german joke i don't
mean to drag all germans into this
but you know the last year the cpac
stage
um seemed to be clear that it was
a a a nazi symbol a lot of people
pointed that out as did i i actually
have a video about it maybe i'll play
that video later on today maybe i'll
retweet that bring it back up in the
timeline
of the video where i'm talking about the
the nazi stage
because it should be called impact i
don't know if you guys seen this and
i'll play this video today we'll get to
it hopefully
is the video of matt schlapp
matt schlapp
saying that they're no longer
conservatives which [ __ ] we knew that a
long time ago you dumb [ __ ]
match slap did not have to tell us that
they're not conservative anymore for us
to know that they're not conservative
but did you know that matt schlapp
runs cpac and the funny part about him
saying that they're not conservative
anymore and him running cpac is that
first c in c pack
it's supposed to stand for conservative
so they need to change it maybe f pack
for fascist pack or
impact for nazi pack [ __ ] so
i'm sure we'll we'll run through that
today of how a cpac needs to change
their name
change that [ __ ] name all together
we had a few more people here susie's
here
robin is here good morning good morning
all
we're going to start the shitless round
up soon i think gabe's going to join us
here at the bottom of the first hour for
a bit you guys always like when gabe
shows up to the show
i don't know maybe he'll be wearing a
wig i can never tell with this [ __ ]
guy i can never tell
[Laughter]
with my executive producer my co-host
rather he's going to show up as someone
else
oh my god did you guys see last week he
showed up as eric trump twice he came in
as a trucker let's see what else what
else was he um the week before he was
twitter support he's [ __ ] gay this
[ __ ] guy is working hard over here to
keep you guys entertained
um he's got a few good good videos also
that i want to show this week at some
point i mean i think he's got some more
being released but the problem is these
[ __ ] idiots are parodies of
themselves and he can't keep up
he can't keep up with these
[ __ ] like every time he gets an
idea to make a video or we get an idea
to make a video like oh let's do this
and like oh they trashed it they trashed
it because they went two steps [ __ ]
further right jesus christ
all right let's let's go down this
timeline here actually you know what you
know what let's let's let's start let's
start the tweety tweets and the trendy
trends
in in a in a in the real fashion that
we're supposed to
in the real fashion that we're supposed
to because today's president's day and
the truth is that truth social [ __ ]
sucks let's start the countdown
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the [ __ ] list
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome back to the [ __ ]
list roundup where we round up all the
tweety tweets and the trendy trends of
the day
of the day
you guys see the marjorie taylor green
here on the screen
marjorie the merge
marge
marjorie taylor green
oh my god walter posted this video
and
she's she's claiming she doesn't want
people to know she's crazy right we got
a lot of topics to get to today but
there's a lot of stuff on my timeline
over the weekend that i'd like to go
over let's make this a little bigger
here and let's see what kind of crazy
this idiot is because she is crazy but
if you notice behind her and notice down
here in the corner it says infowars
so she's going to go on alex jones's
show
and try to convince us that she's not a
psycho
yeah that's the appropriate place to
convince us that you're not a crazy q
and on
tinfoil hat wearing dumb [ __ ] let's
listen in
to captain dummy and it just bothers me
so much they treat me um as if i'm some
kind of crazy person that's the best
part oh that's the best part listen to
the first thing she says listen and it
just bothers me so much they it just
bothers me so much
you hear that we get under her [ __ ]
skin
we get under her skin that's why we
[ __ ] that's why on this show
especially we clown this [ __ ]
because she is a clown number one but
number two it gets underneath her
[ __ ] skin and that's the whole
goddamn point that's the whole point
[ __ ] her
and anyone who thinks like her these
[ __ ] idiots
they're destroying are trying to destroy
our democracy
with their inch by inch little q and on
fascist little walk
towards their nazi america
they treat me um as if i'm some kind of
crazy person that's because you are
you're a [ __ ] crazy person
you're [ __ ] batshit crazy lady
uh like i have three horns coming out of
my head no no two horns out of your head
one out of your ass it's not two three
horns out of your head it's two horns
out of your head one out of your ass but
what they don't understand is they're
the ones that are crazy and
i'm rubber you're glue
on alex jones show this is [ __ ]
fantastic this is where they think
there's [ __ ] lizard people and
they're dropping chemicals from the sky
to turn you into [ __ ] brainwashed
liberals or some [ __ ] doesn't he think
that i don't know [ __ ] alex jones he
doesn't believe any of this [ __ ] he just
makes his [ __ ] supporters believe
this [ __ ]
[ __ ] idiots thank you walter for
posting that walter says walter says
quote they treat me like a crazy person
so i decide to appear on info wars
that should clear it all up
ah these [ __ ] now this this is a great
video as you guys probably noticed i
spent some time on tick tock
i spent some time
on tick tock this weekend
um and i was pulling some videos because
i just thought ah that everyone has to
see this video
and this is a trump supporter and he
does not want anyone to come on his face
watch
let one [ __ ] come in my face
do not come
do not come
i'm gonna come
oh my god oh my god when i see it i
couldn't stop watching i couldn't stop
laughing oh tick tock you're after my
[ __ ] heart
after my heart this weekend i had
several of them that i posted but that's
probably the best one uh this video here
is about the the trucker convoy and this
is also a tick tock video uh bev here
posted this um it's talking about it's
talking about the money and it's talking
about uh not only the money but like
is it a protest is it not a protest
and um
i'm trying to find her handle here
um
but her handle is um
because i don't want to get it wrong
i want to give credit there too
um to her handle go follow her
the person in the video bev posted it
but um her in the video is is even
better and here's here's one with
captions
oh that's a long thread
uh maybe it's in my thread that may be
where this is at
[Music]
yes there it is uh unlearn 16. i'm gonna
retweet this
uh uh lee mcgowan politics girl uh
gave her her us her handle so
go check out unlearn 16 tweet
uh follow her there um
she's got more videos like this you're
gonna want to let me give credit here
for this one
and
let's play the video it's got about 171
000 views so that's good so let's get it
some more views because this needs to be
spread around because she does a
fantastic job of explaining why these
dun [ __ ] in ottawa have no clue what's
going on
so if we can all admit to that i can
move on with my actual discussion
so if we can all admit to that i can
move on with my actual discussion number
one
the protest is misrepresenting where the
focus should be
so if you want all mandates eradicated
the majority of those mandates are
provincially created and provincially
governed you're protesting the wrong
level of government so um in canada for
those who don't know and i know a lot of
you out there are from canada
that listen to the show or been to
canada or know about canada but canada
has provinces which is kind of like
states here in the united states a
little different because they're
parliamentary system but they have
provinces um so when she's talking about
provincial rights it's kind of like
states rights here when these
republicans talk about states rights big
government small government type [ __ ]
actually governed you're protesting the
wrong level of government
and i'm pretty sure that as a group that
talks about freedom and freedom from
government so so so much you do not want
trudeau or our federal government
overriding or usurping provincial
authority to control their own province
number two this has changed from a
protest to an occupation clear and
simple guys you've set up day care this
is really important what she's about to
say with the emergency acts that trudeau
actually used um to start breaking up
this occupation um so listen to what she
has to say here bouncy castles the hot
tub guys haven't got out you have
bathrooms everything is set up for you
to pretty much exist there and you've
been there for three weeks as soon as it
turned from a protest to an occupation
the rules change
and the charter seven rights that you
like to talk about those don't apply
anymore so when they start arresting and
impounding your vehicles it's completely
mandated
number three the money
a lot of people are concerned with these
frozen accounts but millions tens of
millions of dollars are coming from the
united states think about that for a
minute tens of millions of dollars are
coming from outside the country to
change canadian law
if it were any other country donating
this onslaught of money people would be
screaming at their top of their lungs
right
russia china all these countries we've
deemed negative countries or rogue
nations but since it's coming from the
united states we don't
it's the same effect it's the same
impact foreign nationals shouldn't be
affecting our democratic system and
finally once you hunker down and say
we're not moving until you change the
law
what you're basically saying is that 50
000 people if that
have the power
if they're willing to have the political
will and just stay and disrupt
they're able to change canadian law and
usurp the democratic system
that's not the way democracy works
so a lot of important points there but i
love her point at the end and that's
what these people don't get is you're
not fighting for freedom you're fighting
against it
you're fighting against it you don't
realize it it sounds cool that you're
yeah vaccines but number one you're
being duped if you if you went there if
these people actually went there to
protest vaccine like that they actually
went there to protest them and they
thought that's why i'm here that's why
i'm going they in their heart of hearts
believe that right
fine but you were duped you're being
duped you're not there for vaccines
you're there to try to tear down
democracy
why in the [ __ ] would americans anywhere
want to fund
a a occupation
that is under the the guise of a protest
about mandates in canada
that doesn't affect americans and
actually
what it does is it affects the economy
here and there too like when those
trucks can't move across that
that that
that freeway that bridge
they can't commerce can't commence
across that bridge that's why that
[ __ ] bridge was built with public
funds in the first place
is to increase the economy
to have the flow of money
for those citizens in their country and
ours
the flow of money and goods
so you're not you're not you're not
doing this in the gangster freedom or
protesting your jobs or you're being
[ __ ]
duped
into thinking you're fighting for
freedom and um it really reminded me it
really reminded me of this
because they kept they keep saying this
[ __ ] freedom fighter [ __ ] right
we're fighting for freedom we're
fighting for freedom well george carlin
had a special in 1992
and this little line says it perfect
like i can't say it any better than what
george carlin said it so that's why i
quoted and that's why i took this little
clip and i posted on twitter let's
listen to it
well if crime fighters fight crime and
firefighters fight fire what do freedom
fighters fight
if crime fighters fight crime and
firefighters fight fire what do freedom
fighters fight what are they fighting
we're fighting for freedom now no you're
not
anytime anyone calls themselves a
freedom fighter they're doing the exact
opposite of that
in history that's where you see
i said a little something for truckers
claim to be freedom fighters arrested by
ottawa police
of course you know there's several
comments but you go down to the bottom
comments
and you got [ __ ] dummies right
you got [ __ ] dummies
that are all tied up in this
because they've been duped they're
[ __ ] being duped uh jordan klepper
did a good video
um
in ottawa and these people didn't even
know why the [ __ ] they were there
no clue
no clue
no [ __ ] clue okay uh speaking of
canada news you guys probably heard this
general candace owens wants to invade
canada
this is the gqp so not only not only do
they want to back putin in his invasion
right because [ __ ] america
[ __ ] america we should not we should not
back american soldiers and ally soldiers
and the safety of american and ally
soldiers and be on the side of nato
america and its allies and ukraine nope
we gotta back the [ __ ] murderous
[ __ ] dictator putin
you know because freedom and [ __ ] you
people really are [ __ ] dumb and then
and then you want that same that same
army the american army to invade canada
so that way putin can take over in
canada
with his anti-democratic ways because if
you don't think if you don't think that
half the [ __ ] [ __ ] maybe even more
than half the [ __ ] that's going on in
canada with this in ottawa
with this convoy this [ __ ] occupation
this protest whatever the [ __ ] they want
to call it
if you don't think if you don't think
that putin's got his claws into that
anti-democratic message you are [ __ ]
wrong
if there's an anti-democratic message
anywhere if there's a message around the
world that's tearing down a democracy
especially a well-established democracy
putin is all over that that's what he's
doing in ukraine now he's testing
democracy
give a [ __ ] about that border
he knows he's in trouble tyrants don't
last forever they don't and usually it
doesn't end well for tyrants
someone brought it up this morning i
forget who maybe i'll find the tweet
but seeing that it's president's day
maybe we'll just go to the trendy trends
here and see if we can find this tweet
seeing that it's president's day
ronald reagan
what ronald reagan would think
of these [ __ ] and their view
of [ __ ] putin ronald reagan
would be would be backing and supporting
alexi navalny
the person who wants democracy who's
fighting for democracy and is jailed for
it
they think putin's [ __ ] tough they
think he's some kind of good guy
they've got their [ __ ] head screwed
on backwards
it's delusional
let's see if i can find this tweet i
doubt it but we'll see
ronald reagan would have not supported
putin he would have supported america
their allies ukraine and alexi
navalny he would be calling
for vladimir putin
to let alex navalny out of prison is
what he would be calling for
and here you [ __ ] are cheering on putin
thinking he's some kind of tough guy
you really are [ __ ] dumb
let's go back to the timeline here
there's a few more things
before we get into that um wu tang
posted this uh today is john lewis's 80
what would be 82nd birthday
um on president's day no other
uh
past the john lewis voting rights act
today would have been john lewis's 82nd
birthday he's missed dearly wu-tang says
my my view is is that john lewis
we should name election day it should be
a national holiday and we should name it
john lewis day
is what we should name election day is
john lewis day
let's listen
we do not want our freedom gradually but
we want to be free now
we must say wake up america wake up for
we cannot stop and we will not tell our
be
i got in trouble it was good trouble it
was necessary trouble
when you see something that is not right
not just not fair you have a moral
obligation to say something
there's still
work left to be done
get out there and push and pull
until we redeem the soul of america
[Music]
one of the greatest modern american
heroes that we have
john lewis
we should honor him by making election
day
and voting a national holiday and name
it john lewis
day
john lewis gave his blood
for your vote not just for his not just
for mine everyone's vote he gave his
blood
he gave his heart and his soul
he gave his entire life
to devoting to freedom
and voting
and giving rights to people to
participate in democracy
he believed in it wholeheartedly
with his whole being
and so on this john lewis day
his birthday what would have been his
82nd birthday
i i implore you to go out there and get
in good trouble
mayo is here mayo i have missed you
oh i think you got suspended everyone
mayo is here she's on she's on twitch
welcome mayo we miss you a lot we miss
you
we miss you a lot we hope to see you
soon
john lewis day should be a national
holiday
election day
john lewis day should be
and we should celebrate this american
hero
the way that american heroes should
always be celebrated
so thank you john lewis for everything
that you gave to america not just for
people of color to vote but for
everyone's rights and everyone's freedom
to participate in democracy
you are a beacon of hope
and we will continue to remember you and
honor you
okay gabe here says about true social
trump launched his true social app on
president's day because of course he did
get ready for the presidential flop
gabe's making some predictions here
sign up and sign in errors of course or
if you can sign in at all sign up or
sign in at all
uh d-a-u and m-a-u will be sub-optimal i
don't know what that means that must be
tech talk
tech gabe with his tech talk i don't
know organic engagement will be lacking
no product innovation yeah it's gonna
look exactly the same as twitter like
exactly the same ghost town in six to
nine months you're you're being very
generous gabe
you're being very [ __ ] generous
about truth social here
um
giving it six to nine months
uh here he says just downloaded the app
he was downloading the app last night i
just downloaded the app i've been unable
to create an account
clicking the link create new account
gives you the following error screen so
here's what it looked like oh sorry
sorry
you don't get you don't get an account
you don't get an account
so he was trying to log in
um to the uh
the app and matt i'm gonna call out matt
here matt says
i do hope when you're entering your
personal information for signing up you
use tony michael's info and said come on
now god damn it
i'm relying on gabe to make up some kind
of fake information so when there's the
data leak because you know they're going
to infiltrate the data here like if you
go over and you enter your data into
true social no because these [ __ ]
these [ __ ] right-wing [ __ ] suck at
this tech stuff they are horrible at it
they are [ __ ] horrible at it
someone's going to get in there and get
that [ __ ] data and they're going to
leak it and they're going to dump it for
[ __ ] sure
he said you know for when they get
hacked
matt says of course
yeah matt don't give gabe any good ideas
god damn it um and i said me me with
them of course
um let's see what else do we have here
on true social
ah
well let's go
we were down in the rabbit hole there i
think we have i think i had some more on
true social here
somewheres somewheres maybe we'll go to
the thread let's go the tweety tweets oh
here this is this is a this is what i
this one i wrote
would who would pay good [ __ ] money
for these gq peers to delete their
twitter accounts and slither over the
trump's truth social so apparently and i
don't know if this is true or not i
guess we'll find out as as we log in
as we log in oh here we go
here we go here's gabe i think it's
actually gabe that's joining us today
gabe how are you this morning yeah i
heard you talking about me oh did you
yeah yeah all right yeah i was talking i
was talking i was talking [ __ ] you know
i know i know let's
let's let's dig into this the reason i
gave six and now i think all of these
things are going to be true now
foreign
i have a background in
uh in tech i'm a product designer and
yeah you were you were saying some
things here that i i have no idea what
the [ __ ] you were right here you want to
go back to it i'll break it down for you
yeah let me let me let me pull it up
here there we go okay okay let's pull
the bait so
my predictions were that uh people would
have an issue signing up creating an
account and then also signing in right
so so and which your prediction is
already with your experience so far has
already come true right right so that
happened check check
d-a-u and m-a-u are daily active users
and monthly active users
it's a metric that you use to
measure the activity within an app to
say like okay great we're getting like
we set a benchmark here and this is what
we expect now i'm sure like like the
business model is viable because right
exactly because you've got you have
investors right and these people want to
see the numbers to show like okay the
money i'm putting into this thing is
actually going to return something later
on if we decide to
uh
bring in any sort of upsell or
advertising or anything like that
because because what you're saying there
because that's that's actually crucially
important to this whole [ __ ] business
model because they tried to well i mean
they went public with this thing before
it ever really existed and then and then
when the after the all these investors
dumped you know it's like a pump and
dump they pumped all this money into it
and then they lost their asses on it but
that's when they released like what it
was actually gonna be and it's like an
exact copy right yeah and also keep in
mind the other thing i didn't even
include in here was this this app has
been already like redesigned since the
initial like we're coming out with this
uh this app
so that the design that we see today is
different than design that was
advertised and also
shown in the app store which is not
uncommon but it just goes to show you
that the initial design
wasn't close enough to twitter
that they had to then make a copy that
was even more like twitter right well
and i want to i want to bring that up
when we get down to this no product
innovation right um but you said organic
engagement will be lacking what makes
you think what makes you think that
organic activity will be engagement will
be lacking so i wouldn't be surprised if
they had already started seeding so
seeding in in um
in a tech standpoint is when
uh
you
you put in content beforehand to make it
seem like there is already activity
happening but you mean you mean before
like the app opens up and all these
right so you'll want to seed activity
conversations to say like
uh hey you know john doe what's going on
maga for life all that [ __ ] right
right right right so if you wanted to 24
that kind of right right if you wanted
to push a message or or a narrative
right in the app that you control you
know that ecosystem well i say ecosystem
because it's not really one but
if you wanted to control the message
within that domain
that is how you would do it right you
would start to in to to get well right
because you would create an echo chamber
of people who wanted to say the same
thing but instead of feeling like you
were hesitant or shy about being the
first one to say something you'd already
have fake users
fake users right right there'd already
be conversations that people could jump
in on and exactly right right now these
could be actual
users or bots they could be real
accounts but they've already begun the
conversation by saying hey this is the
best app ever or like oh man it's so
great to get away from twitter and have
our free voices
or some [ __ ] like that right freedom
right i'm sure that means so
that's why i say organic engagement will
be lacking because i think they're going
to artificially
uh inject conversations and topics into
the app which isn't necessarily um
a new thing that has been done for other
apps right there's other there's other
these tactics to get people to start
conversations and to get them engaged
however i don't feel like the engagement
is going to be sustaining
in the app long enough to get them to
something to say like this app is is
totally viral right there's a viral
coefficient as well that goes with apps
to say like let's say that i i post
something in the app
and i want to share it i i well i in my
mind right now i have no idea how that
that sharing component happens right
because
you share it out are there going to be a
a public viewable interface that people
can interact with you know like you
would see on twitter and facebook maybe
right that would be like not reinventing
the wheel but
uh i can't say for certain that uh that
trump wouldn't be dumb enough to try to
to to to gatekeep people out
so if you've shared something and i was
like hey come check this thing out on
truth social someone try to go in and
like oh in order to view it you got to
make an account which is so nice so in
other words so in other words like um
because facebook does this a lot right
like you gotta log into your facebook if
you click on like a facebook link right
if you interact like if someone shared
it
and then you wanted to interact with
that that link that took they like they
text it to you right like they right
right
hey look at this look at this post on
true social media right
and then and then the frame click right
typically what you would see in other
apps is i could actually see what that
page is now again i don't know what this
looks like because i'm unable to
actually get in the app as well as
many many other people that i've been
like documenting online
but what i've seen is
typically what you'll have is i share a
link you can see a a
a public view of that however you can't
interact you can't like you can't share
you can't comment you can't you know
whatever you want to do with it because
in order to interact with it you have to
have an account to actually log that
additional user interaction with it
right
now if they share it i don't know what
that looks like uh i would assume again
that they wouldn't reinvent the wheel
but i wouldn't put it past them to try
to gatekeep or like you know it's what
you see sometimes when you go read an
article there's like a paywall kind of
thing where you can't see
you know because you have to log in or
pay whatever not saying that they have
to pay because that ended up being
a uh a debunked rumor okay so so let's
talk about that because the organic
engagement that you're talking about the
lack of it is going to be because
twitter you can go search twitter
without logging in like there's some
there's some things that you can't do
obviously but you can you can go look at
the archive like you can see
everyone's account if you're not logged
in like on a web browser right yeah so
you're saying the organic engagement is
going to be low because they're not
going to just allow that right yeah but
i also think that just the conversation
itself are going to be like very
one-dimensional right you're going to
have to you're going to have the people
who are like pushing a bunch of
conspiracies and the people that are
pushing because remember this is free
speech there's going to be like
literally freezing yeah there's gonna be
little that is left
to
uh
that you can't talk about right there's
obviously gonna be like you know no
pornography and no this and all that but
for the most part they've advertised
this as a
free speech
totally open model no pornography so
that that that's a good idea maybe maybe
now that the ottawa occupation is over
maybe the ram ranchers
i'm just i'm just throwing out ideas
here so let's get to the product no
product innovation because i saw this
morning and maybe maybe this is a
debunked thing too because we'll talk
about the the the
the amount in um
in
in uh
the
the lie about the the weekly charge why
about the weekly charts right
um so 4.99 a week is a myth it's been
debunked snopes debunked it
so where did that come from where did
that come from it came from there was
another screenshot that was taken from
another app and what ended up happening
was somebody tweeted out or shared it on
facebook wit and misled people to
believe that this was
uh trump's app but it was actually
different out so it's not actually 4.99
in a week but though at the same time
it's like i wouldn't put it past him
well i mean hey it sounds right right it
does sounds right it's one of those
things where it's like oh this is is
this parody you know you know the best
part you know the best part about that
though is because these [ __ ] always use
these lies to try to try to [ __ ] you
know put wrenches in the system right
and here it here here is a [ __ ] lie
that is totally believable that will
probably keep trump supporters off the
app because they think it costs five
bucks because if they spread it because
this lies spread around so fast and they
believe every [ __ ] thing they hear
so because they believe everything they
[ __ ] hear and they're not willing to
uncouple it from their brain right like
if they hear a lie and they're like oh
well now it's a lie i can undo that as a
truth in my head nope they got to
continue this lie right right that may
that may hurt the organic engagement
just because they're not going to go
over to the act because
money there could be people who are
there's a deterrent because people
believe that because there is a cost
they don't want to sign up now that's
you know i don't know these people are
so [ __ ] gullible and they might just
pay to pay
and end up you know paying some random
person through paypal because they were
told that they should you know i'm not
saying that they would do that but it's
not outside the like possibility that
somebody would feel duped or or rather
would be duped into doing that right
let's get to the product innovation
because i seen this morning there's like
and maybe this is these would be
debunked too but he stole he stole the
[ __ ] logo like the what's what's the
little app
yeah apparently i don't know that is
possible i mean here's the thing like
there a lot of companies steal logos and
i actually have
a book somewhere in my apartment here
that uh
that is
logos over time right right like if they
are like even airbnb logo like that's a
that's just uber
uber right these are all logos that have
been either used or
modified from
other legitimate companies because a lot
of them are just like
really
very common fonts right they're just
arranged in a certain way or right you
know stacked in a certain order or
something yeah i i don't know uh
i mean here i'm looking i'm reading this
independent article right now that says
uh
truth social trump threatened with legal
action by a little known british company
with identical logo right um i don't
know what the company is
it's called trailer
and both logos use a block style shape
that formed the letter t making truth
social a target of dozens comparisons of
the logo of the british firm interesting
but it doesn't it doesn't surprise me
that trump would steal a logo right oh
no it's not
so the logos are very similar the only
difference is that they modified it by
here i could uh well here here i i think
yeah send me a link and we'll pull it up
here yeah so the the logos are are very
similar um the only difference is he
added a
uh
a little block or something that's what
it looks like on the bottom yeah like a
green little box right exactly and so
when you look at the two you say
oh yeah these are uh
these are nearly identical right like
i'm i mean you know the trailer one is a
little bit longer in the t stem
than right uh so here they are and the
trump one but so this is the trump one
right right that's too social and then
this is the other one which
i mean other than the color in the
little green box right but also the
color is like you're you know you're a
change in hue here on the background and
i'm sure i could match the same thing if
i add a
neon
green block again different colors than
what was originally advertised when the
when the
uh
you're talking about when they first
when they first advertise it and they're
like hey you can like um
you can sign up to download the app you
know the wait list or whatever uh or the
uh get notified when it does go live
there's a different different design to
it
is this the actual company
yeah this is uh i believe that's the
actual company to see donald supports
some uh so this is a this is the british
company yeah this is the british company
that's claiming our people are claiming
that the logo is stolen which it if you
go look at it it does i'm gonna retweet
it here so great to see donald trump
supporting a growing substantially
making uh maybe ass next time so
basically they're saying thanks for
supporting our uh thanks for supporting
our brand trump and making us known all
around the world for the logo that you
stole yeah so this is i mean here's i
love how they're trying to killing
someone's brand is totally on brand for
trump well yeah absolutely you know so
but tell us tell us because you live in
this world of like logos and design and
what you can and can't do it's totally
legitimate to for him the pi i mean
maybe there's legalization i mean other
country but yeah it's it is i mean
obviously different you know different
laws and different rules for different
places but i mean like you know logos
are
trademarked and you know
um
it's a big issue if it's a similar logo
in a similar industry right so this is a
little bit different this is a solar
energy company right he's a sociable you
know social company right yeah
grifter agreement
but if you if you worked like let's say
i wanted to open a shoe company and i
made a logo that was like very similar
to nike right uh nike would just bury me
in lawsuits right and that would be
illegal because i could possibly cause
confusion within the marketplace to say
like oh yeah that shoe that looks like
nike i assumed it was a nike shoe
and that's where you have um brand
confusion
and typically if you're a smaller
company going up against a bigger
company
uh i mean and a room full of lawyers
right right you're done and uh i look at
this and i say like they're not the same
industry the logos are very similar
yet
different so there's probably no lawsuit
or no case here but it does go to the
fact of like the guy couldn't even come
up with an original concept for his
[ __ ] social app right right he stole
the interface the interface looks almost
identical to twitter he uh uh other than
other than the chicks are right
yeah soviet red checks right exactly
instead of the blue or the black it's
just red the soviet right you know but
when i say product in innovation what i
mean is
the app in itself is going to use the
same features that you see
on facebook on twitter
on instagram like keep in mind these
companies
while in their own kind of field
they do copy from each other right like
you had insta instagram made instagram
stories then facebook obviously owns
instagram so they adopted those in
twitter made twitter fleets which is a
copy of instagram stories right linkedin
even made stories uh these are all
things that someone says oh great
there's there's market there's like
traction or mark market adoption within
this feature
uh people really like it let's see if we
can use that in our own app as well and
then call it something else but well
that's that's like twitter has twitter
spaces and it's kind of a copy of like
the clubhouse exactly and i look at
clubhouse and i say that's not really a
product that's just like a feature right
right you know but it is what it is
so i look at that and it's kind of
similar how steve jobs called dropbox a
feature not a product right because he
was like well it's just file sharing
there's nothing really innovative about
it you're just sharing the permissions
now obviously from there they've
modified and allow you to interact with
things so it's become more of a product
than a feature but
um
yeah so there's gonna be no product
innovation
everything that you see there is going
to be everything you've seen before from
every other social app they're just
going to pull and copy it's going to
pull and copy and pull and copy and
they're going to do it you don't think
they'll do it in a way that they'll
they'll actually keep users because
that's that's sometimes social media has
a trouble with that like like for
instance tick tock became really popular
and that's where a lot of these uh
facebook and all the and youtube went to
shorts like they were like oh my god
this is a huge market and they tried it
and they're just it's just not the same
right like right it's not the same or
the fact that it takes them longer than
anticipated to
uh to advocate feature right and to say
they go like youtube uh shorts that took
months like
uh i think they tested it in india and
then they did a test here but there
really wasn't a full-on test you had to
tag it in a certain way right and then
you also had to be larger uh larger
creators or influencers on the platform
those were the people that were going to
be able to use it so i mean like you
know they're using that to generate hype
like oh my god they're using shorts i
can't wait to use shorts right like
right you're using this tactic of
uh of of using influence to network an
idea or a concept to you know to draw
attention now that also goes into
another thing i'm going to talk about in
a second but that's what i mean mark no
mar no product innovation it means that
this app is going to be a clone copy of
everything we've seen before so it's
nothing new yeah nothing new they're
probably going to try to upsell you on
something you know maybe you can buy
some [ __ ] stickers or whatever i
don't know what the [ __ ] is going to
happen right they'll probably be
definitely going to be a griff though
that you have right right the only the
only way and so this is when people were
like you you especially like oh 69
months you're being a real generous
this is why i believe that all right
be up to six nine months
they've uh at least tentatively and
they've talked about it and so is rumble
rumble which is the open
like free speech platform for video
sharing
is going to be
the uh the the back end service for
video sharing on truth social okay so so
explain that what do you mean by back
end so is it like
so they use their bet piggybacking on
another right so instead of instead of
creating or developing your own video
sharing uh
i mean the kind of like is it kind of
like on i mean i mean are they gonna be
able to retweet videos is it kind of
like periscope was to twitter or yeah i
mean like they're using you know i
forget the the timeline of one periscope
came in with with video if it was before
and then they adopted and they said
great uh but i know that live sharing
because that's what periscope was before
and i think that was really the feature
that they adopted right into uh into
twitter but what i mean is
so instead of creating something from
scratch to say like hey we support video
sharing right
they're going to use rumble which is
already an established platform and
service that you can upload share
cut snippet whatever it's like what all
of the other people use like oan that's
why you see all of their [ __ ] on there
all right wing people everyone is
pushing a conspiracy is
there because everywhere else they're
getting completely thrown off because
it's all debunked stuff or it's like
this
right wing or or or um
hate speech or whatever it is is getting
is getting removed from other platforms
and this is the place where you could
say whatever and however yeah i mean
unless and unless it's against them and
then it probably right right unless it's
against them yeah and obviously they'll
suppress it or kill whatever but
rumble's gonna be the service that
supports video in the app right so you
can upload a photo as normal and then
the video component is what is being
driven that's powered by rumble so in
other words you're gonna have to upload
your video on rumble and then no no no
no no no that's what i'm saying what i'm
saying is like you can upload a video
rumble and share it on
truth but when you upload a video
through it's just going on rumble it's
being supported by rumble now i don't
know if it's going to have parodies so
that it goes over to rumble but it will
stay on true social and the video
component is powered by rumble now the
reason that i say six nine months before
it becomes a ghost town is because i
believe
that there can be enough activity to
keep this thing just like above water
right or like up coming up for breath
and then going down and coming up for
breath and going down
ever so often
uh for the app now in the next nine
months there remember the events that
are gonna be happening we've got the
midterms coming up right right so i
think don't you think that's why the
release came so fast is because yeah
there's a lot of indictments coming uh
right he's in big trouble so he wants to
be able to to get his message out there
exactly yeah um and then the midterms
are coming i think that's why they're
pushing it out so quickly yeah yeah and
so i look at that and i say okay well
you got the midterms coming up in
november and they're going to be ramping
up this summer into the fall to start
you know promoting and campaigning and
debates and whatever else and all this
stuff and so they're going to use this
as an app to push
whatever narrative they want right
because it's free speech you can post
you can say whatever and they're going
to push that as its own echo chamber
right we've seen it with parlor parlor
obviously you know nobody trusts parlor
anymore because all their [ __ ] was
hacked right and it was shared to fbi uh
you know uh right people invested yeah
well because of january 6th right
exactly
but now the idea is that uh
when i look at this i say okay we're
leading up to a major event a milestone
and that needs to sustain itself and
after that we'll see what happens but i
think
by nine months it becomes relatively a
ghost town because i don't think there's
going to be enough people actually
talking about [ __ ] what i think's gonna
be happening is uh people who are
running for office
uh campaign managers people who running
the social other people they've got like
as plants people that are or you know
maybe paid on the uh
uh behind closed doors to great post you
know
those people are going to keep activity
going and they're going to be pushing
you know the big lie and they're going
to be pushing this other narrative and
those are going to be bigger voices and
those bigger voices are going to be
amplified artificially and somewhat
organically
by actual users in the app but i think
if you were to drop all of that from the
side you wouldn't have anything to
sustain the app right so that's why 69
months now i don't think people
anticipate i saw a lot of people were
like oh yeah six to nine days six to
nine weeks that's funny how i think how
many scaramucci's is what i want to do
right exactly they're like two scary
moochies
and in my mind because i'm from a
product world i'm like what events are
happening and what would actually keep
this thing moving
till that point or like for the next
nine months and it's the midterms so let
me ask you two because
like
you see tick-tock right and tick-tock
got huge and then there was this and and
but you know it was literally like a
child dancing app right like a trinidad
dancing app yeah it was a previous app
that got rebranded and then and then
what happened was is the politics
started to play in with the 2020
election and you had the two sides of
tick tock you had the the manga side and
then the the liberal side right of tic
tac and then uh tick tock seemed to be
censoring
um
some of the political speech on tic-tac
after the 2020 election and then even
after january 6. so a lot of people left
tick tock to go to what was called
clapper
um
and i don't eat this clapper even is it
even a clapper i believe still exists
because they advertise themselves as the
like right
free speech platform and i i'm even on
there they brought me over like hey
listen if you post you know three things
and do this we'll give you the verified
check mark and i was like all right cool
fine i'll do that and like have you been
over there since
i posted some things and it's like back
in my mind i never remember to do it
right when i originally did it some
things would blow up but holy [ __ ] the
interface was terrible the ux was
terrible so let me ask you is this the
same thing is this the same i mean the
same kind of i mean because i noticed
that aesthetically it looks better
because it's using twitter as the model
now i don't know what the actual
interaction is going to be like i can
tell you from my experience of just
trying to sign up and create an account
it was [ __ ] dog [ __ ] okay so talk
about that talk about your experience
so matt matt tried to get you to use my
information
you son of a no i'm just kidding
obviously he was kidding but yeah yeah
so so what happened so last night uh i i
did that i did that tweet and i was like
all right whatever and then i find out
that it actually you know it actually
was officially live right so i download
the app you know
cool great
so you were able to download it on the
apple store or the yeah i download it on
because that's is that the only place
that it's actually available is the
apple uh as of right now yeah which is
very surprising because android doesn't
have
uh well here's the thing two things i
believe you
apple is the only the app store is the
only one that allows you to like
have a waiting period to say we're going
to launch on this day when it finally uh
does go live then you can download it on
android there's really no approval
process from my experience
uh you submitted app and it gets
reviewed and that's why you find a lot
of shady apps on the android play store
because
uh
they don't really get reviewed like they
give me you mean by samsung itself
before it goes on the store we'll buy
google because they're the ones that
well right right sorry so because like
apple has technically they have a
legitimate review process as long as the
app seems like it's working it should
work then they will say great there's
nothing malicious here there's nothing
that's going to steal data you know
because privacy is a big thing do you
think maybe that's why they did that
though is to like this ruse that a i
think i think they used apple as the
first one because they wanted to drive
up hype right they wanted people to say
oh great boom because as it's safe it's
safe in other words it's safe but also
it's the only one that allows someone to
pre-install so you say oh yeah sign me
up so then when i see what you're saying
like like the pre-order because they
were they were tweeting out the
pre-orders exactly right exactly so once
that goes live the pre-order becomes a
legitimate order aka a download it gets
downloaded onto your phone but android
you can't do that in their uh their app
store you have to download it at the
moment now they they they might support
uh android i don't know uh it's
obviously a different code base and and
uh i mean you could do it through other
things like react but in my mind react
is a
nobody has anyone react is a a
programming language that allows you to
do different types of platforms so you
could do react so you could basically
download an apple
app on your well yeah you design it's
called react native and so you design
the app and you're like great i can
design this component so when i ship it
it goes out and looks like ios i ship it
it looks like android i ship it it looks
like this right so these are you know
you make a react native website all
these different things so anyway uh i've
had more headache than i can
handle from that so i would imagine
these are uh
these are
uh code just like these are platform
specific um
designs so i don't know when they will
if they will do android uh but they've
obviously launched with ios on the
iphone so yeah so so that that that
brings me to it to a question here about
the you know ios and you know
trying to make it seem legitimate
possibly
but really at the end of the day
do they have this launchable by the end
of the day or tomorrow do you think i
mean because really i mean think about
this this is what trump always does
right he always does this like he has
this big hype he's got this this fraud
that he's trying to sell right like
trump sticks like trump stakes are the
best ever and it lasted like three
[ __ ] days because it couldn't launch
yeah because there wasn't anything there
it was all [ __ ] it was just a video
that he did right so do you do you think
that it actually like because it is
apple so they have said that it's
launchable essentially but do you think
it actually gets up and running to where
they can because what's the back end
look like yeah they have a certain
amount of servers or something right
this is what i think happened right so
you
and this goes into another point that i
experienced uh later on because people
were like oh i'm you know i'm in the i'm
i here's my screenshot of the waitlist
can't wait right
this is what i think um
about that uh i think
so for your first question you've got
apple apple goes through a review
process for the code they say this looks
good nothing malicious here we're going
to go we give you approval and then
within a few days it goes live right now
from that point it is solely dependent
assuming the code
looks good from their their dev team to
review
uh and their qa team that uh this is
actually a true social issue this means
that on their end on truth socials end
they
there's a bug in the system either they
weren't anticipating the demand that was
happening or they didn't do properly qa
testing or there's some connection
between how accounts are created in the
database
from
when you enter info to how it's saved or
what the actual flow should be because
the optimal flow from what i've seen in
some screenshots is you get to the thing
it says do you want to sign in or create
an account i want to create an account i
go there i have to indicate what my
birthday is then from there i have to
enter an email then from there it says
great we sent you a verification email
standard kind of onboarding flow right
however
what happens
in this experience for several people
outside not just myself is click that
screenshot yep you get an error that
says
uh something went wrong
right
which is not ideal there's no context to
what we're wrong you get a random vague
error and i'm this is just me trying to
click create an account
just so this is not doing anything weird
like i forgot my password
i mean i didn't even try that uh i just
tried create my account create my
account i would get this screen then
we're trying to are trying to do a work
around where you try to get into the
action right exactly there was nothing
that would allow me i just got this
errors like something went wrong please
try again then i was like okay fine took
some time off came back tried it again
got to the birthday
same error something went wrong please
try again okay fine so little by little
you're getting each npc yeah but every
time i try i mean like i might click
please you know create an account create
an account create account and then i'm
led into the next step right and then i
get the next step and it's like air air
air air and i'm like [ __ ] this so then i
leave and i come back again later
while i'm watching tv or a movie last
night and i click and i get through to
the email
same air same air same air same air i
even got to the email screen
and
submitted my email
and it said hey congrats uh or whatever
we sent you an email to verify
i never got a [ __ ] email still
haven't i still have not got an email
are you able to sign into this thing at
this point no because i haven't set a
password oh okay because you're doing
right so i need to verify create and i
have to go to those steps right there
right there's a bit of like this is
making sure that you
you're getting legitimate people or when
i say legitimate people you're getting
real people right in the app that are
creating accounts right because they
they they really at this point don't
want it completely infiltrated by all
fake accounts because that would be that
would be like a a knife almost
immediately right like if it's all fake
right yeah
i mean at some point they want it to be
fake right right yeah i mean they want
you know obviously fake uh
they want fake interactions in there to
make it look like real interactions but
the problem is if you can't get people
in to actually interact with those fake
interactions then the app is [ __ ]
bust and then what i saw was people were
sending me messages about how they got a
uh congrats your uh you're on the wait
you're on the wait list right
which was um if you go back to that
tweet
yeah let me uh uh let's see what the the
this one here
uh
the third of the three back to the
original yeah and scroll down so i know
somebody added uh keep scrolling down
somebody added a screenshot of them on
the waitlist
oh okay like
right there boom okay so i'll give
contacts to people who have not seen
this or you know have no interest to
actually interact with this app
your account has been created
successfully okay and it said due to the
demand
then uh
we are
uh
you know it says thank for joining due
to massive demand we have placed you on
our waitlist we love you and you're not
just another number to us you totally
are but your waitlist number is below
7717
right so do you think that's a fake
number like they're trying to bolster
that number i think this whole thing is
fake
and the reason i think is screenshots
fake no no no i think the screenshots no
no no no what i mean though is like it
the screen grab is obviously real but
what i'm saying is the screen this
message that someone is getting is bogus
it's not nothing in this is true so this
is this is what i what i think happened
uh and this tactic is also not new to
designing an app right the idea here
is that you want to create exclusivity
there's a hype of demand that is not
actually there
right but it creates people talking it
creates a buzz people want to know what
it is people want to download oh [ __ ]
i'm this one oh i'm in this way these
wait lists are a real thing that have
launched i've worked at companies where
we've done this you know to hype up
demand and it does work so another in
other words
you know [ __ ] works this works so in
other words in the initial planning
in these apps sometimes in design
designers are saying okay we need to
make sure we have a wait list and we
have designs that we're going to pump
out when people end up on the quote
unquote wait list is that right but it's
also it's also one of these things where
you go in saying
if we can't well there's a few things
it's like if we can't handle the traffic
or even
low or high amount of traffic because
people can't sign up we need something
to send someone if we can but also
that's the assumption that someone can
actually go through the creation of the
uh account successfully that's we have
to do to get to this screen
however what's happening here is some
people are getting through to this
screen and everyone else can't even get
through the create an account link right
so what's what's happening is some
people get the account created and
they're put on a waitlist now my
professional assessment as an engineer
and a designer is that what they did
here was they created this to
artificially hype up or inflate demand
which is great totally something trump
would do
right but i look at it and i see
you make this screen they've signed up
and you put them on a waitlist
so now people have waited essentially
twice they've waited once because they
pre-ordered and the second time because
now they're on a wait list
and then
they will
slowly allow people in you know whether
it's for crowd control or whether it's
because they just wanted to hype up
demand and make it seem like everyone
wanted to do it so just intentionally
make people exactly because you know you
know the best part about this statement
here this little graphic is you know due
to high demand we place you in a way it
says we
love you do you remember where when when
he said that as well
what remember remember
the the famous uh uh statement that he
made on january 6 which caused him to
actually that's the actual video that
caused him to be taken down from all the
social media platforms eventually you
know over the next few days he said we
love you in that [ __ ] phrase that is
[ __ ] hilarious i'm i'm almost
surprised that they didn't even tell
people to stand back and stand by
like
like hey
stand back yeah like stand by maybe he
should have had a little had a little
video that he made you're on the wait
list and i think maybe maybe maybe
there's a maybe there's a video there
for uh
our friend our friend john walsh i know
um i'm just you know floating right
there i'm going to join the wait list
right join the weight loss what i find
funny about this is that he's like
thanks for joining due to the massive
van that we created
right
right like there is no demand that we
created right it is no demand that what
has happened here is he created demand
and it would only this would only work
if there weren't a ton of errors in the
beginning right like if you were able to
create an account great boom oh wow okay
well it seems a little odd but i'm on a
waitlist
mj mj points out a good point here mj
says you're not a number you're just
number 7717
right
it goes you're not just another number
to us but your weightless number is
and you're like great you know whether
that's actually 7 717 people i highly
doubt uh
but you know it is what it is can you
imagine the [ __ ] they got number
six six six you know you know these
people they freak out you know i'm sure
it's like i'm sure somebody got it i saw
only two two of these out there one was
four thousand and one was seven thousand
okay so they're not like pumping out the
same number no no no i mean that would
be funny too but i imagine what's gonna
happen is you could also hit the refresh
icon there and it would update your
number to be like oh great i'm number
seven seven oh okay
right you down the list exactly yeah
which is probably just probably just a
[ __ ] automated thing that yeah it's
like every three sec if somebody
programmed it right it would be like
randomly go every few seconds or
whatever it is
so that's what i say this app is [ __ ]
dog [ __ ] it's got no product innovation
the only thing that's going to keep it
moving is the midterms and trying to
push the agenda and narrative of the
republican party or the gqp up until
through november so i don't see this app
actually working how they want it
to work
i think it's going to be a [ __ ] ghost
town
but after the midterms but that's that's
just me and that again that's only one
person's opinion but that's also based
on you but i guess
but i guess you're
you're you're doing the assumption that
they're possibly doing this just for the
midterms which i think that's pop
probably
i don't think they're only doing the
midterms i think they're doing it but i
think the midterms is what's going to
drive the engagement or activity inside
the app in a somewhat organic fashion
it's not going to be enough but what are
they do do you think because um
we elected joe biden right and after
january 6 happened uh well
i'll say this from the election until
january 6 yeah social media really let
down their guard right we know that now
from the whistleblower uh the facebook
whistleblower that said look they had
policies in place to kind of you know
stop some of this stuff from
from taking hold of people's minds
actual users minds and they took a lot
of that stuff away right those tools
that social media could use to not
spread as much disinformation and
misinformation right
to
dilute the masses but after january 6
they got and after january 20th when joe
biden took office they kind of let all
of that go
so
why why do you think the gqp or the
republicans of the fascists are so
[ __ ] concerned because i'll be honest
with you twitter is a swamp
like yeah i mean twitter's not great if
if if anyone was on twitter yesterday
they noticed the the portland and andy
know [ __ ] yeah where someone was
shot um and just the actual the absolute
[ __ ] vile fascist nazi ass [ __ ] that
these [ __ ] were saying these
andy knows supporters yesterday and you
think that do you think that you can't
propagate a [ __ ] right wing message
on twitter get the [ __ ] out of here with
that [ __ ] andy no this morning is still
active and his tweets are still there
now um which you know i i don't mean to
get off the topic of social but you know
i i actually message you there was a
screen capture thing or our tweet
capture thing um
and it's probably gonna be very hard to
infiltrate some of these deletions of
the true social you know deleting the
truth but tell us a little bit about um
this deleting thing did you investigate
that at all
of how this is working on
um especially in this situation where
these
these morons are tweeting stuff that
probably is against terms of service but
might even
be um illegal because it has to do with
the illegal activity that happened at
the shooting in portland um
what is what what is that thing that
everyone's talking about
where you're able to go back and see
tweets that have been deleted oh okay so
uh
there's a there's a tool online that's
called um
uh you know way back machine right
right
and we talked about that in interview
and review you're right
uh with a certain someone about a
certain thing happening in canada
um
so uh which i actually have a clip uh
for us to show um oh dewey yeah yeah
okay yeah good good go ahead so um
the
the tool is the wayback machine some
people have used it probably some people
have seen it before but basically what
it allows you to do is it's an archive
it's a snapshot of moments on the
internet and it allows you to go back
and you can plug in a url like nike.com
or you can go to twitter.com whatever
the tweet is or whatever and you can see
these old tweets you can even go back
and look at trump's old tweets right
right but you can't right now because
it's suspended but however in that
moment in time you could see what was
there
so what you're saying is you can't go on
the twitter app but this way back
machine has almost like a screen capture
thing yeah yeah and you can go back to
2018 and you can see the screen exactly
yeah yeah now there's a tool that
somebody there's a a tool that somebody
developed that allows because this is
most important for journalists who want
to go back right and they want to find
the receipts of people who have said
deleted tweets not tweets that you have
remained up yeah they deleted one so
basically it uh you run it local you
download it through a github repo but
you download the project and you can run
it locally through a terminal and you
basically say like what dates you want
from the range you say what the username
you want to look for and it will find up
all of the uh the deleted tweets it also
gets you screenshots as well so it's a
very useful and powerful tool that will
use the wayback machine assuming
that they um
uh that that page was archived right so
assuming there's a snapshot that was
taken by a wayback machine then it's
using their api to actually pull it so
in other words if you if you post a
tweet and it was up for four or five
minutes it likely there is a screen
unless it's exactly i mean like you
might find that in more like high
profile accounts because those are ones
that are being tracked more often right
those are the ones that are like you got
a lot of engagement so you're trying to
take as many snapshots because there's a
lot of people coming to that uh with the
potential that something changes
uh but if you're a smaller account and
there's not really a lot of activity
going on you should be careful your
deleted tweets are going to be out there
for everyone right exactly yeah so
basically if you tweet out the internet
that you don't want forever
you know just just pretend like it's for
now see if anyone wanted to know the
internet is
forever this is somebody very
complicated this is very complicated for
me and here's why because in the morning
when i'm tweeting and i don't know if
you guys know this is
i actually smash the tweet button as
soon as i finish the last character like
i don't go and read that [ __ ] i
don't see like oh did i change it and
not get it right and you know nope i
pushed the [ __ ] button gabe knows
this yeah
we've had several tweets that we've
tried to put and i think it's been
mainly like the the bonehead of the week
right
yeah yeah i [ __ ] it up and i'm like
change it
change it i'm like no what what's the
difference no one will notice he's like
no change it because i i literally when
i'm done writing it i push tweet i don't
normally go back and re unless it's
something like really important right i
want to get right i i smash the tweet
button and especially in the morning if
i have not had at least one or two cups
of coffee this way back to or whatever
is it's going to get me in some [ __ ]
trouble um but i mean you don't say
anything crazy well right but i don't
delete a lot of tweets i don't know
you're not going in to say anything
racist or sexist or whatever
or anything like that these tweets these
tweets are important gabe what i'm
writing is very important the things the
things i put i mean didn't you see the
the come on the face video that i put
out this stuff funny this stuff is very
this stuff is very important okay just
like news breaking stuff so um let's do
you want to play you want to give the
audience an idea of possibly uh just a
little bit of a nugget because i think
it'll be tomorrow or wednesday that will
release this this interview and you guys
are definitely going to watch this um it
there is it's it's like two hours
yeah it's a little over two hours
um so
we interviewed uh a guy by the name of
high fidelity he's a co-host of a
podcast radicalized uh truth survives
podcast you can find them on uh twitter
at uh radicalizedpod you can find them
on uh youtube at uh radicalized truth uh
survives podcast uh yeah actually we
actually interrupted cuda right we had
she's another co-host uh jim stewartson
and sean uh
sean conner
um
so high fidelity context his background
is uh
he is uh you know as he put it long time
tech nerd right and that is layman's
term for i've built
systems basically internet systems
between companies and countries and how
they talk to each other
um back end front end like everything
you can think of how everything goes
together so
um
there we had a conversation with him
about what's happening in ottawa and
these this campaign these donations that
are coming in and the gifts and go
because specifically to give sen go i
mean at first the obviously uh flags are
raised when it happened with uh gofundme
but the data leak and hack happened with
gifts and go and so
and there was a lot of news about that
last week about the big donors right
like right right
in the interview and we're talking about
that yeah and we talked about that but
what he focuses on in our interview is
he focuses on the other ones that are
happening behind the scenes like
everyone knows about this person that
person how much they donated but it's
exactly
who like these other small accounts and
how many times they're happening the
frequency they're happening at which and
the time codes and
he
essentially i mean like do i just say it
right now do i say well i mean yeah you
can okay well essentially he's
he
kept digging and he has discovered what
appears to be money laundering it seems
like a washing machine yeah basically
it's a he's washing money they're
washing money through the gifts and go
campaign or were trying to
um
and not only not only does he make these
assumptions but there's the in the data
that was dumped and the elite um he
finds little little nuggets of
information that no one else is looking
at because everyone else is looking at
the big donors and trying to figure out
who you know like like the guy from
texas i think his name is
ben it's benjamin pogue with po
construction um nice to meet you ben um
so this guy not only gave uh i think it
was twenty thousand dollars in the
amount through the gibson go but this
guy is giving private private uh jets to
the trump campaign it's like 238
thousand dollars
in some way right people right right
and the the funny part about that guy
specifically is that
trump pardoned his dad
right which is kind of funny you know i
guess a pardon could cost maybe 238 000
a private jet possibly i don't know i'm
just thinking
you know he went or he was convicted of
uh tax eva or tax fraud tax evasion you
know whatever but that's but that's been
the story in the media because it's it's
this you know it's got all these
connections and there's you know private
jets and it's kind of the sexy story
right right but this story is actually
telling a story that i think is way more
important and is there no one else's
cover that i just right that the the the
big high
high donors the high amounts the donors
with the private jets right that seems
like a ruse yeah that seems to be
something to yeah kind of shield you
from this other stuff that high fidelity
was able to actually find should we go
ahead and play the clip yeah okay let's
play the clip so i looked at email
address to zip code first name last name
to email address
email address to credit card type
this is what i found man over 2 000
email addresses appear twice what the
[ __ ]
204 appear three times
46 before and you can see the numbers
right right right right there is one
email address that appears 16 [ __ ]
times now wait a second wait a second
that seems that seems totally fine now
wait a second now wait no because
because if i wanted to if i wanted to
donate 16 times i might use my email
address the same email address each time
and that is absolutely fair and i
understand that and that is organic
right i did look through some of the
duplicates and i found there were some
people like i was able to identify
people and i'll show you that later on
there were organic multiple donations
right that's right what makes these
different well let me show you so what i
found here here was the first one i
looked at right and this was four
records so i have four donations i have
four different names
as you can see right there donation
first donation you're saying the first
and last name are completely different
on each one of these is where you're on
each one we have alyssa jordan
richard and jerry
right okay it sounds like all of them
sounds like a whole family of them yeah
yeah except all of them have the same
email address
with four different zip codes what the
[ __ ]
for this is this isn't like a house you
guys can't just share emails what the
[ __ ]
well so here's my thought right
maybe these emails are emails that have
somebody that will answer any questions
to that email but they're using that to
launder the donations to that email does
that make sense like hey i've got this
one
email the email is the contact point in
other words yeah yeah we don't have
phone numbers right right right so like
it's like if anything goes awry and they
need to respond
there's a person that might have the
email but there might be these tentacles
of donations that are tied back to that
and they're trying to
maybe they're trying to hide by
different zip codes and different names
of who actually has that email right you
look at this one there's three from the
united states there's one from canada
right i actually went out and found the
email address and i did find the email
address it's in japan
so
this is this is
this is very very crazy so you guys
gotta tune into this interview because
he totally goes through line by line and
of course in my true fashion i'm i'm you
know cracking jokes the whole time
because i you know i can't i can't
believe that these [ __ ] idiots would
actually um
make sure that it would be so easy to
find if there was a data dump and here's
the reason why the same reason why i
this has to do with true social is
because ultimately and i want to ask you
this question ultimately there is going
to be a [ __ ] hack and a data leak of
true social yes just like there was a
parlor just like there was of this
gibson go
every every time these [ __ ] right
wingers absolutely [ __ ] suck at this
tech stuff right that's why they're
always pissed off at the lift is big
tech right because they just [ __ ]
suck at it yes look at security
um you know that probably doesn't have
anything to do with russia either but
so my question is back to the true
social
go watch the interview but really quick
because i think that this is relevant
with this data dump
how does this happen and and
how are you protecting yourself when
you're signing up for these apps like
how does that work like so
the best way to
if an app is good about it you'll have
you know use things like two-factor
authentication right so that you can
talk about that in the internet right
right and so for people who don't know
obviously if you should like there are
certain things like one you should
definitely use a password manager you
know there's like one password lastpass
there's a few other alternatives out
there um that way you've got a you know
you've got a master password that
unlocks your vault of passwords and
those passwords you can generate are
random characters letters numbers
symbols whatever
right nothing like your birthday right
you want to be like oh i live on the
street right
something you can remember right exactly
those are things you don't want to do
because those are the ones that are he
easily hacked right
and uh
more times than you know none then
you'll find that those
accounts that have been hacked using
that that password you've probably used
that password elsewhere right because
you're like it was easy to remember so
that i used it for the email and use it
for my bank account i use it for this
thing and that thing anyway
uh there's also a thing called
two-factor authentication that i
mentioned and we talked about the
interview like you said and what that
does is you can use it in apps like uh
facebook and twitter and uh and
instagram these like more high-profile
profile ones but also the ones that
actually
want to have your account secure you
set up
uh in a use like uh google password
vault or there's authy or other ones
that you can use
that basically how it works is you try
to log in and you've got this account
that's tied to it and it says okay go
tell us the six digit code that's
associated with the account and so then
you go to the uh
the um
the passcode manager and you see get the
six digits and you're like you only have
30 seconds or so to enter it in before
it recycles and gets a new one so that's
how you know it one is secure so then
you add that in and then you're good now
there's the other way which is you can
get a text message so if you get like
whenever you're trying to verify
something and you get a right like a
code right right exactly and so when you
get those um that's the same type of
thing you're getting a text message to
verify that you actually are the one
that is requesting to log into whatever
that service is but now if you don't
have that then people are able to just
go willy-nilly and try to do whatever
they want but that's why it's so
important with this interview right and
and and i i know it does it doesn't
sound like true social and this should
combine but it does in that aspect where
all these emails are exactly the same
right and you guys got to come watch it
because he breaks through the data he we
look at like the actual data and again i
i don't normally do this type of thing
but i tried to make it simple try to ask
the questions that would make the data
explain because it is very complicated
and i think that's why most people won't
pay attention but
my my guess is uh from the interview
that we had i think a lot of people that
are on gibson go
had their [ __ ] uh infiltrated but not
only that i think some of the
information was was already information
that had already been infiltrated from
somewhere else exactly right and so it's
one of those things when we talk about
the interview it's like you've got
emails that have been
either that's a
because they're trying to capture the
two factor
you know that's what they're trying to
do if there's a problem with the
donation or something someone's that's
why they put the email in that's the
same way right well you're creating an
account but i don't even think gibson go
has two-factor authentication if i'm
being well right i never use that but
i'm going to tell you straight forward
from this christian website i don't know
what it is but i'm going to tell you
there are two things that remain
constant all of my experience in comedy
and in tech
right wing conservatives
are terrible they're terrible well they
don't know how to build they don't know
how to design if they do design their
copy if they copy it [ __ ] if they try to
code it themselves it's dog [ __ ] that's
why you've got clappers [ __ ] you had
the [ __ ]
uh
that's right it's gonna be [ __ ]
right uh
any other there was that one there was
that one app that trump made during the
campaign that also got [ __ ] owned
because everyone was given negative
reviews which was hilarious
um
they
also it's like can someone point out one
[ __ ] funny conservative no
no not one that's what doesn't mean they
parody themselves if you can right they
do or they try to make fun or like
whenever they try to go on a rant and
complain about something then they
actually expose themselves further from
being more of a bigot but at the end of
the day it's like i'm gonna you know i
hold these truths to be self-evident
it's a fact that tech and comedy
right-wing people are terrible at it
shocks to suck
mj says i love gabe oh thank you yes and
and ann asks is there a link to the
interview so anne we're hopefully going
to air this interview uh tomorrow or
wednesday gabe is still working on
getting the full edit done so hopefully
tomorrow or wednesday we'll be able to
air it um we will tweet it out i'll
tweet it out and we'll make sure we'll
spread it around so be looking for like
when we're going to air this but um you
guys if you're not already
definitely subscribe to the youtube
channel
that way you don't miss this because it
will be on the youtube channel
rather it be in tomorrow's episode
wednesday's episode we'll probably also
post it in and of itself but it's
probably going to take up most the
episode anyways because it's just right
at two hours we do two hours anyways we
have another interview i'd like to
squeeze in so maybe we'll squeeze those
two together um so you guys can watch
them both in one show and we'll just
play the video basically i'll come in
we'll play the video and and you guys
can watch both interviews um but i think
it is a very very very significant
interview in that
a lot of people aren't paying attention
to this and i think there's more cities
stuff as hifi goes into
as we tick through the data um it is
really interesting on who's behind it
too um like the names that are behind it
you
you will kind of uh [ __ ] your pants as
it were to know that holy [ __ ] this this
is this is a big deal because it's not
it's not like small names behind it
right right right like you think there's
big names that seem to be like he even
reveals and i i made a comment i was
like man they are so bad at this because
you know he's able to make connect these
dots between people
and certain groups that's just with the
data that he has with the data and
they're any and they just do a terrible
job of covering it up they're like oh
okay well if i look if i reverse look up
this email or i reverse look up this
person's name right oh i actually find
on linkedin or i find on this other
service that they're actually connected
to these other people right and these
other people have had a history of doing
similar [ __ ] right right and then you
can track down that [ __ ] the other thing
that i think is significant on this
interview is how this isn't the first
time no this is not the first time and
and that also leads you leads back to uh
big name big money people um when you're
talking about this data leak and this
right wing [ __ ] and this fake ass just
just fake ass [ __ ] outrage like in
canada where they're saying it's all
about the vaccine and it's not it's
about tearing down democracy so uh do
you have any more time left yeah okay
well let's go to a break and then um
we'll be right back after this break
we'll be right back
mark
60 seconds this is the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
are you annoyed by masks infringing on
your rights do you wish you didn't have
to comply with biden's communist mask
mandate are you tired of wearing masks
that actually fit your face
well now you don't have to be
introducing the droop with our patented
droop technology every mask is uniquely
molded to not fit your face just send us
a selfie and we'll have one of our
drupists mold the mask for you elastic
free thanks to the droop i don't even
need to pull my mask on anymore it just
sags that way the droop lets you
customize from a selection of pre-worn
masks lipstick stains included make sure
to order your droop today drew be the
spread you want to see in the world
catch tony's twitch stream the [ __ ] list
roundup at twitch.tv slash the tony
michaels
we're back to the king of brilliant this
is the tony michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
don't forget
to check this interview out that we have
with high fidelity
it's gonna be it's gonna be a good one
uh again it's it's a long interview
there's a lot of information but we try
to break it down we try to make it funny
um and you'll see you'll see some of the
names and stuff um
you know
i want to go through a little bit on
this topic that happened this weekend uh
because we're speaking of right wingers
and false ass [ __ ] and fake [ __ ] we get
to andy no uh oh
yeah dildo uh
yeah milkshake boy right so um andy no
and and his ilk um decide to
um
oh geez
to
basically threaten people with their
lives and
um someone actually gets killed um in
portland with a gun
um and then they start to try to
propagate
try to propagate the
fact that um
let me see if i can find it here i don't
want to um
um here here is here's the i don't like
to show his [ __ ] but here's the [ __ ]
lies that he spreads is um
uh last night there was a mass shooting
in portland
uh let's see
uh armed antifa and left militants were
gathering for a direct action so in in
typical andy knows style it's actually
it's actually quote unquote antifa or
leftist that gets shot here every time
he shows up to some sort of rally he's
ready to go
with somebody filming and somebody ready
to say that it was antifa despite the
fact that he's hanging out with the
proud boys he's the one that's making up
stories about getting hit with the
chocolate or the with a concrete
milkshake he's the one making he's the
one who got hit with the [ __ ]
dildo here here we see silicon
silicon rod this is disturbing i just
i was just struck in the back of the
head with
this silicone rod it's called a dildo
andy yeah um currently in route to
hospital with a concussion so a dildo
gave this guy a concussion if you're
wondering how soft he is yeah and people
will use any means necessary to cause
violence they want me dead or they just
want to send the message that they'd
like to you know you know throw dildos
at you right i mean he's also i
mentioned a second ago too he's also the
guy there was a story and he got picked
up and a lot of right-wing people
conservatives were pushing for him to
say yeah we should you know this is the
why antifa and everyone is bad he made
up a story or at least in the moment he
made it seem like it was believable
because what he did was he said that he
got hit with a concrete milkshake right
right
and there's photos of him now concrete
milkshake means they took a milkshake up
and put concrete in it
yeah they put the concrete mix in there
and threw it at him and there's a photo
of him with you know concrete mix all
over his face and stuff and he's like uh
that photo got shared around he got
covered and was put on shows and did
interviews and all the stuff
ted cruz was supporting him other people
were like all the right wing people then
what ended up happening was
he made the story up the story was
totally fabricated he actually had it
done to himself and then blamed it on
antifa of course he did well this is all
this portland's [ __ ] in the earth's
place with where these proud boys you
remember uh several months ago the proud
boys showed up in portland at a walmart
parking lot i think it's a walmart or
kmart or is that the one where they
smoke bomb themselves yes they smoke
bomb themselves and they were
overturning their own vehicle there was
like literally a video also of the proud
boy throwing the smoke bomb and the wind
blowing it back in their face
he threw it nobody threw it for him
right no nobody nobody had a fan it was
just mother nature saying [ __ ] you it's
great it's great uh and binge your
resistor here says last year when andy
noah got hit by a flying dildo i assumed
it was
ted cruz
fleeing to cancun again
oh
avenge your resistor you're after my
heart thank you for the for the tweet so
like so um you remember the andy no of
course i [ __ ] hate this [ __ ]
yeah i mean never also out here in l.a
they also had a they had a another uh
protest that was at a spa
out here in la and he was posting videos
and there's the milkshake here's the
fake
right this [ __ ] guy
but same time it's like any of these
events that happen he's always there
with the proud boys in support blaming
antifa when it actually is himself
looking in the mirror well yeah i mean
they're setting up cameras
and they're having people dress up as
antifa because right anytime you see
andy knows antifa like he's blaming them
and they're committing violence that
they they're full garb no mask you can't
you can't even see their eyeballs hardly
right yeah but look around the corner
you'll find proud boys or andy know at
any of these things right now uh chad
loader um they they actually
um are hard
on andy knowing go after him pretty hard
um and i think chad was actually
suspended um
i don't know what was it probably a
month or so ago
well i don't remember what it was it was
that it was a picture it was a picture
of the reason that chad was
uh suspended is because
uh chad had shared an image of andy no
with the nazi symbol
and then andy noe came over with a a a
copyright claim
right and it's his photo that it was
that it was uh and it was andy's photo
and that chad should be um suspended
over it okay
how'd that work out for him well he got
suspended or
chat or they they got suspended and um
then
chad was let back onto twitter right and
and he's continuing to go after andy
because he says andy yeah yeah well i
believe that andy also coordinated uh uh
you know
you know chad and his family or chad and
and their family um
andy has his followers have gone after
chad right like uh violence yeah he's
got he's got a he's got a farm he's got
a farm that i mean he's got and he knows
got almost a million followers which is
surprising why
why twitter lets him still propagate
this [ __ ] lies when the when it's
provable lies but chad air says andy
noah is now spreading misinformation
that last night's mass shooter was an
innocent victim of an antifa attack
nose followers are responding by
threatening to kill even more innocent
people which is funny because they were
also cheering that the person who was
shot was antiva like it's two sides of
the fence here they they do both things
this is what nazis do this is what
fascists do they use misinformation they
spread lies on both sides so you can't
tell what the [ __ ] truth is um and of
course chad is all over the truth here
you know and the truth of andy noah and
exposing him to be a [ __ ] fraud
because he is but back to the uh andy no
nazi picture i actually i actually got
retweeted by andy know
when that happened yeah because i said i
think i said something like um
do you i don't need a picture to know
that andy knows a nazi like
i think i think is what i said uh let's
let's let's go because i got a couple
things that i'd like to show that i
retweeted yeah um over the weekend
because it wasn't just um these these
andy no types dude
andy knows [ __ ] followers are [ __ ]
crazy they're they're they're they i
don't know how many accounts twitter
accounts and social media accounts that
they've had to go through i'm also
surprised that annie knows still has a
verified account right what that's the
other thing that i was gonna say is how
this [ __ ] because he claims to
be a journalist right i mean that's
right well a journalist
let's look at the journalists who are
making [ __ ] up right right like what's
her face from uh
laura uh that's a good point fox that
that ted cruz was pushing the
fake
what's your name
laura something laura lauren laura
something
logan laura logan she's one of the the
ones that is constantly on on um yeah
the the list of andy knows supporters
and this [ __ ] right um let's see where
is the andy known stuff that i
retweeted um
i'm not finding it here real quick but
um
here is here's something
caleb posted this this movie this this
is some andy knows supporters type
supporters oh
now that man ordered this tweet oh yeah
here's us
here's
us yeah whoa we didn't talk about the
snuffs listen to the end yo say hi to
chad hill hitler
wow yeah so i mean this is this is all
over the
and you getting some of these you know
again say hi to chad they're saying hi
to chad
loader there i believe is what they're
saying yeah hal hitler um so these
people are [ __ ] despicable and what's
crazy is they're like we're not nazis
and they do all the nazis yeah then they
yeah like all the nazi [ __ ] all of them
and i even i even tweeted um because i i
love this i love pissing off andy knoll
trolls [ __ ] nazis [ __ ] them i i love
pissing them off because i know that if
andy knows trolls are coming after me
i'm saying the right [ __ ]
right like they're in my if they're in
my thread if they're threatening me
fantastic i know i'm the one saying the
right [ __ ] thing and i'm on the
right side of history here especially
with [ __ ] like this guy owen um of
course because he said that i think i
reported this video because um
he said that [ __ ] in the video um let's
let's go um
to
another um
video that i'd like to talk about
um
and it has to do with right wingers here
it is here uh not to change topics too
suddenly but i've got a couple of things
i want to touch we got we're 43 minutes
into the second hour so we've got about
15 minutes left here um this is well
let's go back and read each of these
radical republicans running for
michigan's attorney general want to
overturn the right for married couples
to use contraception without being
prosecuted that's right you're hearing
it correctly
married people they don't want them to
use contraception this is [ __ ] real
this is a debate
of these republican candidates these are
the republicans the gqp the nazis in
michigan
michigan michigan
right this is real this is a real
[ __ ] thing that these [ __ ] nazis
are doing and if you don't think that
this is [ __ ] fascist nazi [ __ ] that
not only not only unmarried people but
married people can't use contraception
you you [ __ ] people are brain dead if
you haven't figured out that these
people are fascists and they're not even
[ __ ] hiding it anymore listen
how would each of you stand
on griswold versus connecticut but my
understanding is
griswold versus connecticut
was with um
birth control
prophylactics diaphragms
sponges etc
this case much like
roe v wade
i believe
was wrongly decided because this is it
was an issue that trampled upon states
rights it was an issue that should have
been left up to the states but i'm all
about states rights and limiting
federal and special federal judicial
activism
listen all these cases uh that deal
drizzle rovers wave jobs these are all
state-run issues how do each of these
stand
on griswold
so
in griswold was talking about
contraception so what they're saying is
they want the ability for the state
specifically the the top law enforcement
officer attorney general running in
michigan wants to make sure
wants to make sure that they can [ __ ]
they can they can actually ban and
prosecute
for married couples using contraception
it's [ __ ] bonkers ass [ __ ] and that
these that people out there like yeah
republicans look they are nazis
that's what is happening they have been
infiltrated it is not a thing where the
republicans seem to be fascist
they are full-on [ __ ] fascist and if
you're not if you're not if you want
more proof you know who matt schlapp is
matt
i love his name what a [ __ ] idiot
would you change your name if your name
was schlapp i would
slap a ding dong
at least she's a [ __ ] fake name
my body my choice not
right so patriot takes as this match
shlap uh clip from steve bannon's trader
tv as we call it here um he claims that
the cpac audience is the most diverse
thing you'll ever see
sweaty there's a lot of pigments in that
white crowd right that's what he claims
in this clip that's the the quote that
patriot takes pulls out i think there's
something way more significant
about this clip let's take a listen uh
and so if you ever think if you ever get
somebody lecturing you on cnn or someone
else about how the conservative movement
which i don't use i call it the american
movement because that's all it is we're
no longer conservatives we're american
wait a second
match who is matt schlapp who is
manchester what does he do do you know
what matt schlapp does for a living
he's the head of he's the head of cpac
do you know what the first c in cpac
stands for
conservatives yeah so here's a pack now
it's going to be apac well also is it
only white people that are americans i
think it should be impact nazi but yeah
but literally he is
they are not even hiding the quiet part
i've been saying for years that they're
not conservative they haven't been
conservative they've always used this
[ __ ] thin veiled conservative to hide
their fascism you know debts deficits
all that [ __ ] right
and here he is here he is saying the
quiet part out loud we're not
conservatives i'll back it up
i'll back it up
how the conservative movement which i
don't use i call it the american
movement because that's all it is we're
no longer conservatives we're americans
who love our founding
when they lecture you that we've lost
the kids and lost people of color and
lost women please for the love of god go
to cpac look at that audience it's the
most the first thing you'll ever see
right right right i mean i guess i guess
if you include the golden calf that they
had last year is diversity you know i
mean maybe yeah also there are so many
goddamn cpacs i don't know which one
he's talking about right right how many
do they have
i don't know multiple but whenever
people talk about cpac i'm like didn't
that just happen i just made a sketch on
this and like oh it's a different one
right the new one it's coming around so
so apparently the other news about cpec
if we go to the seat back thread uh nick
fuentes which oh god jesus nick fuentes
is going to hold his own like cpac thing
you know you remember at one of the last
seat backs right
um he wasn't allowed in they kicked him
out he had right into [ __ ] idiots
with him he had his own little uh
meeting well yeah he had his own alpha
cuck army right right um but but they
had their own conference paul gosar went
there to spread their nazi lies i mean
it's basically a nazi rally yeah for all
intents and purposes it's a bunch of
fascists acting like fascists saying
fascist [ __ ] the fascist um but
apparently he's gonna have another one
uh another you know event across the
road from where see this cpac this
current seat back is gonna be here
here's what i i wanna ask the audience
because i think this is important
when we talk about messaging here we
talk about pro-democracy things there's
one thing that that big tent democrats
right the liberals don't do
we don't have like this one event why
don't we have this one event why don't
we have like l pac right yeah why don't
we have that why shouldn't we have that
like i think i actually think we should
all get together in one space
and and
circle jerk each other on stage get oh
aoc up there get bernie sanders up there
get elizabeth warren get get all all the
people that they hate the [ __ ] most
yeah that they hate the most get them on
stage let them talk let them scream into
a microphone because there will be tons
of clips about it there'll be tons of
clips they'll be [ __ ] just triggered
as hell or
or they call it the apac
right
and
uh there you go and then that way
americans right or or or you could call
like apex right apex predator yeah
that's it yeah that's it but i think if
they if they if they called it that yeah
sure totally i mean one you've the only
the closest thing that we have is the
dnc when we're like going through
nominations it's already done when it's
already done not when it's like hey just
as little like because what the i will
say what cpac does is it's like um
like you got a a you know like a little
pond or a body of water and you throw in
uh a bunch of small little stones right
and it makes little ripples little
ripples but like the ripples continue to
the other side so it like it keeps
boom bouncing back and coming together
so the whole body of water has ripples
and those are the that's that's these
little mini c packs they have all the
time right they have bigger events that
make bigger splashes but these little uh
these little events that happen around
those like little pebbles then you got
the dnc they got the convention right
and that's just like throwing one big
massive stone in every so often
not not multiple times a year but only
when people are running and then that's
it right they're like oh we gotta we
gotta make sure that all the delegates
vote who they want for president and
this and that right right
and it gets in the weeds and it gets
into you know because we talk about and
i talk about a lot the separation
between politics and government and the
right is so much better at this and
that's what cpac is this circle jerking
and i know like oh we don't want to do
what they do
they
they win without having ideas right like
they imagine imagine us who have ideas
and people liking the ideas that we have
imagine us doing the whole circle jerk
thing
with the ideas how [ __ ] powerful that
could be how powerful it could be
because i i actually believe there's a
lot of trump trump voters who wear
[ __ ] maga hats that if you actually
go line by line through the [ __ ] that
aoc says they would like yeah i like
that yeah totally because again like not
a lot of the stuff is radical these are
all like
conventional ideas in the sense it's
like i want free education i want free
health care i want to have this i want
to have this i want to have a pain wage
that i'm able right a decent wage i
don't want to go broke if i have a
medical bill
none of these are like crazy like these
are not these are not radical ideas
these are just human rights and that i'm
saying i should be paid fairly i should
have access to free healthcare or just
healthcare i should have access to good
education i should have access to uh
right and everyone should everyone
should exactly exactly but then this
isn't radical this isn't radical exactly
but that's what i'm saying is because
those ideas aren't as radical as they
say right but but they do a really good
job of messaging oh those crazy liberals
those libtards when i had communist
socialism you know and destroy you and
all the cabal and all this just [ __ ]
absolute nonsense
but they they leak that into the minds
of people
what i'm saying
is
that we can do that with the truth and
we can do that with these little ideas
if we just propagate everyone hates the
word propaganda but if we just propagate
the truth if we propagate the actual
policies that are gonna deliver the
stuff that americans want because let's
be frank a lot of people who voted for
trump were pissed off because i know a
lot of people who wanted to vote for
bernie who were pissed off that voted
for trump who were pissed off and those
two things do not even right just
frustrated americans didn't see their
voice being heard or represented and
they wanted a better alternative
unfortunately they voted the wrong way
well correct correct well but but here's
the thing is that is that the
frustration because a lot of people
don't understand um
how the government works how our system
of government works i mean they've
convinced a whole sloth of people that
we're not a democracy like we're not
democracy we're a republic like yeah
well that's what this republic is is a
is a
constitutional democratic republic it's
a democracy but you know whatever but
but they've leaked so far into people's
minds i think i think we can do the same
thing with the truth it's going to take
a little bit of time but if we don't
actually come together as a whole as a
collective and say look we need to be
pro-democracy who you know we can [ __ ]
and argue about the line item [ __ ] in
the government right right how much
minimum wage is supposed to be when
you're supposed to start school how much
does school cost and who does it cost
and
how much cancellation of student debt
you're going to get what how much health
care you're going to get and all that
you know the line items [ __ ] it's
prescription drugs
campaign finance reform all that stuff
we can do but we can't do it if the
fascists take over exactly and if they
can win a messaging campaign with no
[ __ ] no [ __ ] ideas like they don't
we used to i say this a lot
they know that we know their ideas suck
but they don't even have ideas anymore
like literally matt schlapp is going
we're not conservatives and the reason
why we're not conservative is because we
don't adhere to conservative values
that's why he's saying this right all
those conservative values that we used
to talk about we're not even there
anymore so we're not conservatives we
have to use a even more umbrella blanket
term like americans which really pisses
me off yeah but that's what they do so
why not why not the left democrats why
not us do the same thing we can do this
with the [ __ ] truth because literally
if we stay pissed if we have strategic
outrage
we can actually [ __ ] carve these
people up into little [ __ ] pieces as
far as as far as their ideology and the
reason why is because they don't have
ideas on education they don't have ideas
on what people want for health care they
don't have ideas on what people want for
wages we do and and if you break it down
by by doing the politics of getting
those people to vote and have democrats
start to argue and do those things in
government
people who aren't fascist who identify
as republicans will compromise right
they're gonna compromise eventually and
those districts where where there are
republican mainstays they're not as
republican as you think they are because
of that
they aren't they aren't so i don't know
it's just a little thing that you know
democrats deliver republicans destroy we
have to stay pissed we have to go
[ __ ] vote and i believe that partying
the go [ __ ] vote is just not marking
the ballot we got to get out there we
got to organize we gotta have events you
know we can't be we can't be scared to
the word to propagate and propagate a
message and send a message loudly
clearly and over and over and over again
and the more we do this because the
media is not going to do it for us for
sure they always say oh the media's
left-wing and they're helping them out
[ __ ] come on
yeah i don't i look at it and i'm just
like
democrats you know i know that you know
we go high when they go low you know all
that stuff
but at the same time
they're doing a pretty good job when
they're going low i'm not saying that we
have to go low as well but i do think
that democrats take the moral high road
and they say well
we shouldn't do that right they lose the
messaging they right and that's the
thing right again like if you're having
events that are that are two plus years
away from each other where it's like
everyone gets
uh together
then you're missing it because you're
gonna fall you're gonna lose people
along the way who get converted over
because of the other messaging is like
you're frustrated you're mad well you
should be because the government isn't
doing what it should be when that's
actually not what's happening right then
then if if you have these years apart as
opposed to you know cpac which is like
every six months
or or fewer or less we're coming in
they may have they may have to start
having him every week because right but
they're but yeah and so like you look at
cpac and they're just driving at home
and it's not just this convention right
there's other
tangibles
where they're continuing to push the
same narrative maybe some fractures here
and there but it's consistent throughout
where they're just saying the through
line is democrats are bad and they want
socialism and they're gonna take your
guns and they're gonna do this and a
bunch of this and blah blah and all this
stuff and at the end of the day it's
like none of this is true none of this
is true
but she says guns babies right exactly
right like whatever her face is from
right oh my god it's perfect but if you
look at yeah the the holy trinity of all
things that are
that's their message is is babies jesus
and guns all those three in a soup
together right but you look at the cpac
and that's what they're good at is they
are good at just repeating the same
thing doesn't even have to be good and
like you said they're shitty ideas but
the fact they just keep saying over and
over and over and over and over again
is beating people down to the point that
they say
yeah that's true they're right they're
correct that's what we need it looks
like our friend jeremy london says the
democrats are trying to fight a bull by
patting it on the head that's a perfect
way of describing jeremy perfect we play
it too soft we play it too safely we're
just like
with time and and with
with help we'll be able to fix a problem
no it's not going to be like that
because you're the other [ __ ] ramming
through like a bull well the other thing
too that pisses me off about the you
know
the left because
we say the left but like it's more than
just the left like there are right
wingers in the left now right like yeah
gone so their party is so fascist that
even right wingers are in the left now
like in the left but here's the thing
is
when when
jeremy's saying pat the bull
on the head right
right good good bull but here's the
thing is you
you can't even you can't even come to
terms with
like one idea can sell all these ideas
right
like one one message one thing
they have they have jesus guns babies
like literally that is the parody have
you ever seen the movie the campaign
yeah like like that is like like the
whole movie is about that that little
thing right right it's a parody and it's
and now they're in the parody but
democrats liberals leftists moderates if
you are pro-democracy we can have a
pro-democracy message like that like
literally we can have a pro-democracy
message that is three words that will
blanket all those [ __ ] issues whether
it's [ __ ] healthcare rather it's
[ __ ]
whoever it is whatever it is oh here's
john walls jesus guns baby or all we
need
maybe a video coming from john
but but listen this we can do this same
thing and it doesn't have to be gross
and this [ __ ] thing where they're
spreading lies and misinformation we can
do it with truth we can do it with
democracy
it can work that way we just can't be
afraid of it right democrats get so
afraid of of saying and it's that whole
thing we have to be morally right and
again it's not saying you can't be
morally right but the fact that we are
our own deterrent we we play it too safe
we're like well they're gonna no people
people will eventually find the way and
you're like no that's you if you ignore
them they're going to walk away right
what if they but gabe what if they call
our m m's not sexy what if they do that
we can't do that we can't oh my god what
happens
and then they control the near they walk
away in the goddamn go-go boots and
we've never seen them again right right
that's what's going to happen well
it happens that way so if you want if
you want to continue to hear the message
and really honestly you should stay
tuned um this week because either
tomorrow wednesday we're going to drop
this interview with with high fidelity
it is [ __ ] fantastic it has a ton of
information in it um about uh blind
mind-blown you're like yeah this makes
sense but then you see the data and
you're like and you're like whoa [ __ ]
it's way bigger it's way bigger than
just a couple emails on the same
donations exactly way bigger than that
the information leads back to way bigger
stuff than that so don't forget to
subscribe
to the youtube channel
make sure you stay tuned this week we
will let you know on twitter when we're
gonna launch that um we're trying to
find a partner distribution again
because we think it is so important to
have this interview in front of many
people as possible
because we think that the narrative is
being lost because it is a very
complicated thing like when he goes
through this data it's super [ __ ]
complicated but we try to make it as
easy as possible in this interview and
maybe went back on to try to because
he's going to dive into some other
information and
eventually get some new stuff so pay
attention to that but again just stay
tuned every single weekday noon eastern
11 central here on youtube twitter
twitch do not miss an episode and you
can go to all your great directories
even the ones that are heavily boycotted
you can go to apple spotify google um
all those all those things maybe
eventually you'll find us on truth
social
yeah maybe maybe
yeah
do you think we could get over there and
[ __ ]
probably cause i mean why they probably
can't you know if they put it if they
take us down then that's not very free
speech of them yeah well you know i i
doubt it's about a fascist but well i
don't know you know it lies social i
mean truth social we'll see maybe maybe
we'll create an account on there until
tomorrow until tomorrow surf's up
[ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking